between matpat and eric voss in new
rockstars
the theories just don't both sound so
plausible at a certain point
what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today
we're gonna watch from film theory
excited to check this out
the dark truth of wanda's stolen
children i've seen a lot of comments
come in asking us to check out uh the
wanda vision clip for the episode that
comes out at midnight tonight as curious
as i am to check it out
i prefer to just watch the episode in a
few hours
and let that be part of our reaction
which will be up tomorrow keep a lookout
for that subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
the episode 7 reaction is up in the
meantime
let's go through this now i gotta admit
i was surprised that one division
decided to go with a malcolm in the
middle homage for their 2000 sitcom
because there was an
absolutely perfect line they could have
used if they had gone the scrubs route
[Laughter]
hello internet welcome to film
so much craziness happening in this
incredible disney plus series i'm doing
my best to keep you all up to speed but
with our production schedule and this
show's time jumping mechanic sometimes
feels like i'm decades behind
would that our editors had the speed
powers of quicksilver
how was it that pietro got his powers
again he volunteered to be experimented
on by
hydra all right edit team listen up have
i got a vacation plan for you guys
of us releasing it the fact that wanda
is the big bad of her own show despite
the fact that she may not know how she's
doing it the fact that she's most likely
piloting around vision's dead body
the fact that she had been to sword
headquarters before the whole who might
be an accomplice with her disney or
someone controlling in some way
to the x-men i know our hit ratio on the
channel ain't always the greatest for
prediction
that was like the home run of episodes
now we're just waiting on the big reveal
that sword dude over here is the show's
real big bad
and the fact that the kids will either
disappear or be taken by sword before
the end of the series
but let's just stop for a minute to talk
about that touchy little subject of the
kids
by now one thing should be pretty clear
wanda maximov's twin sons billy and
tommy
are a major part of both the wand
division story and the mcu
as a whole but where have all the other
kids in town gone
in episode 5 vision raises this exact
question wonder why are there no other
children in western
oh sure in episode six we see them
running around for halloween festivals
we also don't get ourselves an answer as
to where they were before
and why they're only showing up now
where were you hiding all these kids
up till now i assume they were all just
sleeping peacefully in their beds no i
you're always the empathetic twin i
don't
i didn't now that could certainly i
don't i didn't
attempt to deny that she's controlling
the world or more likely
she doesn't actually have a full
explanation for this
as we heard in episode five do you
really think that
i am controlling everything that i i am
somehow in charge of
everybody in westview and again here in
episode six
i don't know how i did it or maybe she's
in denial
could be completely alone so today i
wanted to dig into all the kids stuff
what's the deal with west view's
children and how does it all relate back
to tommy
billy the show's ending and the reality
of the mcu
moving forward if you're unfamiliar with
these two characters billy and tommy
have had a weird life
in the original comics canon billy and
tommy were just aspects of scarlet
witch's belief their babysitter a 500
plus year old witch noticed that when
wanda's life was in jeopardy
or when she was just distracted the kids
would inexplicably cease to exist
despite this they still somehow managed
to inherit their powers from their
mother
and uncle you heard that right their
uncle please don't ask me to write a
theory about
that superheroes wiccan
and speed eventually wanda learns that
her kids are fake and her mind gets
wiped so that she forgets about him
until of course she doesn't anymore and
then goes sicko mode on the yeah
thus far because they're the only living
things to come from nothing
it's an easy scene to overlook because
it was in an episode full of huge
moments but in episode 5
we got this yeah they're real those
pants
are 87 percent kevlar it's not an
illusion
wanda is rewriting reality she has mad
didn't just conjure up new clothes for
monica she rearranged the materials in
the kevlar jacket that monica was
wearing
to create a new period appropriate
costume what's more when wanda wanted to
create this fictional reality
she first had to steal visions are you
saying she took
one of the kids facing with the mind
stone and his body
i'm afraid
needed vision's body to complete her act
within the confines of the town
she's not creating matter out of nothing
to make this reality it's all coming
from somewhere looks like someone
learned a thing or two from watching
full metal alchemist
something of equal value must be given
this is the law of equivalent exchange
for further proof look at when wanda
herself leaves the bubble unlike
monica's clothes
wanda is wearing her normal outfit when
she leaves the hex and while it's not
super clear because marvel did a good
job of keeping it out of focus there
doesn't appear to be a wedding ring on
her left hand
her ring of course was something that
was conjured out of nothingness in
episode 1
but because it's made of nothing it
shouldn't exist out in the real world
what then does this mean for wiccan and
speed are they
conjured from nothing and therefore
can't exist outside of the bible
or if they are real what are they being
conjured from well we know that they're
gonna have to be real eventually
not because of anything in the show but
because of the wider business
there's just a whole slew of new young
heroes that are gonna be hitting the big
and small screens over the next two
years
cassie lang ant-man's daughter just got
recast from end game indicating that
marvel is seeing her as a bigger
character going forward
literally as it's likely that she'll
eventually become jai
ant girl or stature as cassie lang tends
to do in the comics the hawkeye
disney plus series is centered around
clint passing the torch to kate bishop
and later this year miss marvel is
supposed to get
her own disney plus show and all of this
is without mentioning spider-man and
some of the other long shot guesses that
are coming down the pipe this lineup
alone would create a solid foundation
for a new team up and another giant
crossover event
the young avengers and who are critical
members of the young avengers
kids i didn't even
think about that possibility of them
being a part of the young adventures
i thought that would be just some
terrible fate that they'll meet
at the end of this series just a device
to generate anguish
yeah i really thought that's where it
was going kind of riffing a little bit
more on house of m and stuff like that
so that would be pretty neat if like you
have wanda turning into a villain
or taking on a bit of a villainous path
all those terrible things come from it
but something great and beautiful and
heroic to come from it would be wicked
and speed which
kind of does go a little bit in line
with the introduction of
wanda and pietro in age of ultron they
were stemmed from hydra something that
was not
exactly a positive not good but then
they
went down the heroic path so like their
mother and
uncle they go down that path as well and
what a
piece of dramatic weight for them to
carry that their mom
you know is conjure them through such
dubious means
you know like what a uh uh you know
painful
thing to have to deal with as characters
if they choose to you know do that
i love that wiccan being especially
prominent you see wiccan was something
of the face of lgbtq representation in
the avengers for a while and it looks
like marvel is gearing up for more
representation in the mcu moving forward
in an interview with seriousness
an actor who cameoed as the first openly
gay character on screen
said this who else is gay uh but we're
gonna find out you know there is a
gay character coming up in uh one of
their films i think kevin will make that
announcement
with wiccan just becoming a prominent
character in the universe and disney
here's our gay cast all the eternals are
gay
gayness represented
they have to survive outside of wanda's
protective bubble well part of me
really really wanted wanda to have used
westview's children as the raw materials
to create her
that's where i thought you were going it
seemed like it might be a bit too dark
for disney
and in episode 6 seeing her children
alongside other kids from the town
kind of shot that theory down
prematurely but if the biological
building i like that theory
i know where then are there just be a
couple missing kids you know what i
think
comes from science in episode 4 the
character darcy throws out some
scientific mumbo jumbo about
wanda's reality bubble my equipment
registered an extremely high level of
cmbr that's relic radiation dating back
to the big bang
yeah now that sounds like the sort of
stuff that a writer's room would make up
to have a character like darcy sounds
smart but cmbr is a legit thing that may
just give us the proof that we need to
crack the whole wandavision mystery wide
open
you see cmbr or cosmic microwave
background radiation
is a faint glow of electromagnetic
radiation left over from the big bang
the initial discovery of cmbr was made
when some technicians working on an
extremely powerful radio receiver
couldn't understand where the faint
static they detected was coming from
as scientific american explains it quote
it is the residual
heat of creation the afterglow of the
big bang streaming through space these
past
14 billion years and the most
interesting thing about it is that it
falls on earth from every direction
with practically uniform intensity which
is why when darcy picks up a whole lot
of it coming from wanda's bubble it's as
amazing as darcy makes it out to be
the only reason that that would happen
is if there was a birth of a whole new
universe within the realm of that bubble
wanda is legitimately doing the same
thing she's not just
reshaping this one reality she is
tapping into another universe which is
sending out its own
cmbr waves it's important to remember
that the mcu wanda has her origins with
the mind stone
after just stay mutants at one point and
we'll be happy yes
confirm it for us telekinetic and
telepathic abilities
which uh i gotta admit it's kind of
creepy when you consider that the mind
stone basically
created her and now she's married to the
empty husk where the mind stone used to
be
and we've seen that wanda's had to take
some mastermind shortcuts to make this
reality work like the stores for mops
locksmithing flooring and plumbing
in short wanda is a first generation
playstation 4 trying it's hardest to
render cyberpunk 2077. yeah she might be
able to get
most of the basic pieces in place
there's certainly a lot of wonkiness
going on
and episode 6 starts pointing this out
explicitly we're treated to these
terrifying shots of citizens on the
periphery of wanda's attention being
forced to endlessly repeat their actions
while tears stream down their face
these people near the edge of town
they're barely moving
are they alive children it would seem
are specifically harder for wanda to
control
kids can't control them
how hard to try yes especially her
own kids she can't put him to sleep
she's unable to stop them from aging
themselves up i suspect
it's because they're not her magic
between the cmbr waves and her inability
to control the kids i get the sense that
they're from
another universe that they've been
pulled into this reality by wanda's
subconscious
or some other more nefarious source
that's using wanda need more proof
pietro remember wanda can't just create
people she needed vision's body and
westview to use him and she rearranged
monica's clothes rather than conjuring
new ones so where did pietro's body come
from
well if we assume he is who he says he
is and isn't some sort of
undercover agent hey i'm not some
stranger
and i'm not your husband you can talk to
me that is just a weirdly suspicious
line there pietro
it leaves our only option as him being
pulled in from another reality and in
this case
i don't think it's a coincidence that
the episode pietro first appears in
takes place between the late 80s and
early 90s that time period
is the same time period in which dark
phoenix the final mainline fox x-men
movie took place
new mutants accepted but that's kind of
a whole separate thing the mcu's
born in 1989 would either be unborn or
babies when this episode was taking
place
so she couldn't just grab an alternate
reality version of her mcu brother
if wanda wanted a brother in her weird
time-shifted universe he would need to
have been born
way before then like ideally in the late
50s so that the ages would match up in
the fox universe quicksilver was
born in 1956 which would make him a
perfect late 20s
early 30s to match wanda's age by the
time they hit the late 80s early 90s
wanda's powers subconsciously found her
a perfect candidate
a brother that would temporarily match
her age
as she's flash forwarding through the
decades
this being a quick silver from a
different universe it would explain why
wanda in episode 6 doesn't remember
pietro's childhood story exactly the way
he tells it worse than the costumes mom
made is the year we got typhus
[Music]
that's not exactly how i remember it
would also explain why there's a 1950s
era nuclear propaganda poster on the
wall next to the old woman's house
division if he's from the universe don't
really have a solid explanation for that
one but here's the thing i just don't
see a world where the multiverse doesn't
get mixed in as a result of wand
division either all of these characters
wiccan speed and pietro are the
creations of wanda and they just
disappear at the end of the show
leading to wanda ripping open the
multiverse to find living versions of
them to reclaim her happiness and
jumpstart the next phase of the mcu or
they are all real and it's revealed that
she's unwittingly pulling them in from
other universes since you know she can't
just have conjured them
out of nothing but she didn't pull i got
a question about this
goddamn between matpat and eric voss
vossen knew rockstars
the theories just don't the multiverse
one is the one i'm most likely
to believe but damn when they put up the
arguments of either like nightmare or
mephisto being
the one who's really manipulating things
or possibly it's really quick silver
it's just marvel stunt casting like both
sounds so plausible at a certain point
this sounds the most plausible is the
one i
my mind went to but my question about
pulling wiccan
and speed over is they're aging they
started off as
babies and they're aging rapidly fast if
she were to pull
kids over wouldn't she have had to have
pulled kids
from another universe that aren't like
rapidly growing you know what i mean
yeah
well it doesn't account for that exactly
and if they are
real or based on real material no one
else in west view you can see that
so would the theory be that like pietro
this version that we're watching now
the common theory that's been going
around is like the pietro pulled over is
the one between
between apocalypse and dark phoenix as
presented in this video
or would it be that pietro was pulled
over from 1956 in the world when one
division was taking place in the 50s and
then he aged and got to this point
like what what exactly is happening here
that i know that's the part about this
theory that like
it sounds plausible but i have a hard
time buying it because of the fact that
they started off as babies and started
growing
i i thought we were going down more of a
path of she created them created life
and we're talking about big bang and all
that
yeah well and i love that side of the
theory i feel like that has maybe
something to do with it because that
could explain just why she can't get a
control over
i feel like if she made them she would
be able to control them yeah you know
at least intentionally she can't just
have conjured them out of nothing
or heck there's always option number
three maybe disney went real big brain
and my initial impulse was right wanda
used the children of the town and
remixed them to create heroic i
personally
think that would be so cool and like
messed up
powerful new villain for the next phase
of movies doing something like that
would definitely fit the bill but hey
that's
just a theory a film theory
and if you're interested in getting more
marvel theories make sure you've hit
that subscribe button
we do them all year round even when
there's nothing to talk about in the
marvel universe for instance on screen
right now is my related theory to this
one about how
thor is also signaling the collapse of
the multiverse i heard that right
wanda is opening up the multiverse and
thor is shutting the whole thing down
that theory is clickable on screen right
now so make sure you check that one out
if you missed it and i'll see you all
next week guys
this was fantastic another fantastic
video
yeah i mean i feel like we've said all
our thoughts in between yeah
what it is let's talk for 20 more
minutes but from everything that we've
talked about from
hopping between our own personal
theories to new rock stars to here
i'm just excited to finally get uh
hopefully we get a concrete answer here
because yeah i mean like that's just
basically it i i think that
there's a lot of sound reason to the
fact that they've been pulled from
another universe that would make sense
the only thing that puts a little
unless someone can explain it in the
comments it's not explained here why
they start off as babies and start
growing like that doesn't make sense to
me well maybe quicksilver next episode
will age up and that'll
solve that that's what i mean it's a
quick silver agent yeah like there's
some that's the thing about a lot of you
know and no one else is aging when
they're going through the decades
yeah and i mean that's what they're
they're not even aging through the
decades they're aging
before her eyes yeah like they're
skipping
you know kind of wherever they choose to
go it seems like
yeah so i don't know but the idea of
them going to young avengers i think
would be really cool
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below keep a lookout for a one
division reaction if you haven't
subscribed to film theory do yourself a
favor subscribe and they got
plenty plenty plenty of amazing videos
they got to be at 10 million
sooner than later catch you guys soon